the best part of the story is I did
watch the VP of marketing uh for for Bud
Light she came on and she said look uh
she felt like the brand needed to be
more inclusive and they needed to get
away from their frat beer uh image right
because those son of a don't
drink beer no and so uh she said she
quoted she actually said female
representation is a personal passion
point of mine right so what does she do
she goes out and gets a guy with a penis
you know and says hey I want you to
promote my beer right well horrible yeah
I mean it's it's it's just it's bizarre
right but again I go back to the same
thing I guess at the end of the day I
don't mind pointing out the stupidity of
that yeah but I honestly on the other
side of the coin I don't give a
what people do